judge The Pact says that the gateway to
disruptive criminal activity often
starts with unlicensed documents and
Relics
I know the sixth episode of Silo ends
with what feels like a big reveal it's
been established that access to
technology is limited but the final shot
appears to confirm that the rule doesn't
apply to everyone you also find out what
Juliet's plan with the Pez dispenser was
if not what she's trying to accomplish
with it as that plays out you get a
detail from the pack that says the
gateway to disruptive criminal activity
usually starts with unlicensed documents
and Relics and as she sets out to find
out the truth about what happened to
George we get flashbacks to their time
together to help develop a clearer
picture of why he became obsessed with
the Silo's biggest questions none of
this is terribly surprising with
hindsight you can see how they were
emphasizing the lenses and Camera
references in holston's use of the
flowers in front of his mirror but what
works about this reveal is that it only
answers part of the question even when
we see that room with the monitors that
you'd have to imagine is in the
Janitor's Closet Sims came out of last
week what does that even mean he
described the people behind that door as
doing the most important work in The
Silo work that he claims keeps 10 000
people alive but why and for Who The
Sims lead them as his father did before
or is this just a small part of
something bigger Jules is trying to
discover the truth and she engages with
the most intriguing Relic yet at the end
of the episode why is the idea of what
the world used to be like something that
people are not supposed to be curious
about and do the people who suppress
that information all know what the truth
is and why they do what they do
the episode opens with an intimate
memory of Jules and George in bed
together and through a series of
flashbacks it shows us that he hadn't
made much progress in understanding the
answers to those big questions Jules is
thinking of him as gaining access to
Doug trumble's apartment is taking a
long time because apparently you need
special keys to open an apartment that
someone from judicial lives in not
wanting to wait any longer she takes
things into her own hands and grabs a
crowbar to force her way in you think
that they're looking for Clues as to why
he would want to kill marns but when
Billings finds the Pez dispenser Relic
in the medicine cabinet you realize that
this is all part of Jules plan this is
all going on at the same time as the
Forgiveness holiday Bernard was talking
about we don't get a direct explanation
of how that works but we do see a sign
here and it reads in light of recent
incidents and in the spirit of Goodwill
Community and commerce citizens are
encouraged to let go of past grievances
to travel Beyond on familiar levels to
see old friends to give gifts and to
spend credits in the marketplace where
crafts of all types can be acquired we
also get the sense from other
conversations that there's a type of
immunity that applies that people can
come clean on things that they've done
but again this isn't explained in detail
so it's not really essential to what's
happening back at her office Jules tries
to look up the Pez dispenser in the
relics database by entering the
description yellow plastic blue handle
the search comes back saying that
there's insufficient data and I think
this is funny because I had been
wondering why they chose this specific
Relic it's not something that I
remembered from the books and I wondered
why they made this specific choice and
the best I could come up with is that
most people who are of a certain age in
our culture understands what this thing
is but it would be really hard to
describe it or understand what it was
for if you didn't have that context and
I think this search kind of underlines
that which is pretty satisfying we see
that a porter brought her a note from
recycling it says didn't find what you
were looking for I'll let you know if
that changes and she doesn't say
anything about it and goes the extra
step of destroying it after she reads it
Paul Billings arrives at the same time
and we get this great little detail
about him finding out that there is a
pack competition to find out who knows
the most about it and that he's won it
four times which is more than anyone
else I wasn't really sure what to make
of this character early on as he didn't
play a big role in the book series but
based on these small details that
they're adding to his story and the way
this actor's bringing him to life he's
fast becoming one of my favorite new
characters she explains to him that she
wants to do her own investigation into
the Pez dispenser and she thinks she
found the way to justify that through
the pact but through him she finds out
that if she wants to do it that way she
has to go to judge Meadows and get
approval and he says that she doesn't
interact act with many people these days
they go there anyways and they meet Sims
who's there waiting out front the judge
says she's not feeling well and that she
wants to get this over with quickly and
you get the sense that there's something
wrong with her but it isn't clear what
it is both her and Sims look surprised
that the Relic was found in trumbull's
apartment which tells us that they think
that they would have known about it
before if that was true Sims explains
that judicial knows more about relics
than what's in the sheriff's database he
points out in a somewhat threatening way
that he knows that the watch he wears is
registered to George who's a person that
she said had been murdered she claims
that working with Holston helped her to
see that his death was actually an
accident and we should remember here
that in the last episode before he
killed him Sims brought up the fact that
Trumbull had made a mistake when dealing
with George even though Sims makes it
clear that he doesn't believe that the
Pez dispenser belonged to Trumbull he
does tell Jules he thinks A Relic
investigation might be a good idea but
that she needs to take Billings with her
since he knows more about the pact in
typical Jules fashion she tries to ditch
him immediately and he makes it clear
that now that she's on Sims radar
they'll be watching her everywhere she
goes it'll either be his guys or the
whispering friends of The Silo so he
needs to be with her at all times she's
not exactly on board with this but she
realizes there isn't much that she can
do about it and confides that she knows
a guy that's been busted with relics and
owes her a favor that turns out to be
Patrick Kennedy and he turns out to be
afraid to talk about relics at all he
says that in his experience people with
badges doing things for personal reasons
tend to get people hurt Under Pressure
though he does eventually give them a
name back in his office Sims examines
the Pez dispenser he finds it right away
in a search in their database and finds
out that it is pre-silo but there isn't
much else on the computer then we learn
and he also has a giant Vault of relics
behind his desk and volumes of something
that look like journals they look very
similar to the books that the mayor had
in her office once he opens that up you
see a lot of intriguing stuff on those
pages to Circle back to my point earlier
about why the Pez dispenser was a funny
thing to use for this I thought it was
great how the person who was charged
with explaining this filled out the
description under function it says top
bends back to reveal Central internal
pillar can Rey's then reposition and top
closes it's a pretty good job if you
have no idea what a Pez dispenser does I
also noticed a date in there it says
that it was first retrieved 7160 I don't
know if that really gives away anything
but it's something to take note of I
mean we know that the rebellion was
supposed to be 140 years ago does this
number indicate conclusively that this
is something that was written before
that happened probably probably not but
I feel like it's at least possible he
flips through some of the other pages
and then at the end he finds a report
from a confidential informant saying
George had this Relic but when they went
to search for it at his apartment they
couldn't find it we do get a lot of
flashbacks where we get to see Jules and
George together and there are some
interesting details mixed in there it
seems like her stealing it's shitty tape
as she likes to describe it was a whole
Caper that she pulled off with George's
help rather than the requisitioning
story she's been telling which involved
distracting dogs with bacon and a lot of
running apparently this comes out in a
conversation where she doesn't
understand why he would take such risk
to have all of these relics where he
points out the risks that she took to
get this tape she explains that she did
that because the tape saves lives and
that she was taking the risk to protect
everyone not for selfish reasons so she
doesn't get the idea behind the relics
because she doesn't see the point of
risking getting sent to the mines or
getting sent outside for things that you
don't even really know what they are he
has an effective counter for this saying
if these things aren't worth risking our
lives for why do they make it a risk to
their lives to have them them this is
very similar to what Allison said to
Holston back in the first episode the
bottom line is that they don't know
George believes that these were all
tools at one time and he's going to use
them as Clues and that's how we get to a
discussion about the biggest questions
about the silo he also gives her the
watch which is a legal Relic and even
though she jokes about it you can tell
that she loves the gift this turns out
to be very important because this is
something that people identify when they
see it first Holston and then later Sims
there's another conversation where he
talks about history just being the
traces of a whole lot of people over a
whole lot of time he asked her if she
ever thinks about the world Outside The
Silo and again she defers to this idea
that she's the one that keeps things
running so that dreamers like him will
stay alive and at that point she shows
him that she fixed the watch and he
learns that she had to make the tools
herself remember she does like to fix
things that's an important part of who
she is is and then she awkwardly tries
to say she loves him without saying it
and that turns out to make it an even
more touching moment so what does George
think is the biggest question about the
silo I mean he thinks there's quite a
few of them what's outside what's beyond
the sensor beyond what they can see on
the screen why are they there how long
have they been there and how much time
do they have left when pressed on what
the biggest one is he goes with what if
everything you know to be true
everything you've been told by the
people you love was in fact just one big
lie and this is probably something that
Jules wasn't ready to accept while
they're having this conversation but the
further she gets into this investigation
the further she gets into her tenure as
being Sheriff you can imagine that she's
starting to think about this a lot more
back in the present they follow up on
the name they got from Patrick Kennedy
it takes them to Regina Jackson's
apartment she also notices The Watch
right away and tells Jules that it
belonged to her boyfriend it becomes
clear in this conversation that she had
a relationship with George and it didn't
end well as he moved on to Mechanical
and she enjoys explaining how bad of a
person he was and how he used her to buy
his relics she explains that she's
already talked to judicial that she's
already told them all of this
information and that makes it clear why
the investigation of his death was on
their radar she figures out that Jules
was likely in a relationship with George
as well and takes every chance she gets
to explain how she figures that he also
used Jewels for his plans she twists a
knife on their way out asking if she
believed it when he said that he loved
her and Billings picks up on the fact
that Jules is visibly shaken when they
get back to the station Sims and Bernard
come in to confront Jules about The
Relic they have the same confidential
informant interview that points to
George having it even though they
couldn't find it when they searched his
place and now it magically shows up in
an investigation that she's leading
which could suggest that she had
something to do with that according to
sims's point of view she denies ever
seeing it before and when Sims starts to
accuse her Bernard actually saves her by
bringing up the idea that if Trumbull
was the one who searched George's
apartment then it's at least possible
that he could have taken the Relic home
with him Bernard still favors the
official story that marns and Johns died
of heart problems after Walking The Silo
and thinks that digging into this
further May undermine the stability of
The Silo and he ends the discussion
there after they leave billing expresses
some concerns about the way that she put
this together he has a family and if
this had somehow come back on him he
could have been sent to the mines or
sent outside and while we're not exactly
sure where his allegiances lie he has
this connection to judicial that we can
can't really Overlook the way that he
just asked her to be honest seems pretty
sincere like he seems like the kind of
guy who's just trying to make the best
out of his situation and she makes a
plane that she can't commit to that when
he gets upset she turns the tables and
exposes his secret the thing that she's
noticed about him that he has the
syndrome and how that disqualifies him
from having the job he does and
essentially undermines everything he
says about upholding the pack for the
greater good an interesting detail here
is the way that she interprets what he
says is him calling her dishonest while
he was really saying that he only wanted
her to be honest with him going forward
he's trying to build trust this is
something that she doesn't appear to be
capable of and when he brings up the
idea that everyone agrees that the
reason marns and Holston were so good
together was that they looked out for
each other she says look where that got
them it's all pretty harsh when you
think about it and that's exactly what
he does he heads home and I don't think
there's much else that he can think
about at this point he's very stressed
out about the syndrome conversation
she's not wrong when she says this
disqualifies him from holding the job
that he has and that lying about it is a
big deal we see her walk through the
cafeteria where she runs into Lucas
again and this time he's waiting for her
it's a cloudy night where he can't see
the stars but he showed up anyway and
that leads to a funny back and forth
about how bad he is at talking to women
as painful as that is she does smile and
even though she says it was not with him
it was at him you still think about what
Walker said about George making her
smile and basically that that was how
she knew there was something real going
on there at the same time Billings heads
home and you see him with his wife and
child behind closed doors he's shaking
much more and you get a sense of what he
has to lose if people find out about his
condition the four-time champion of the
pack competition is lying and committing
all kinds of crimes and the process of
trying to take care of his family you
hear him say I'm thankful for you and
Claire I can't imagine Life In The Silo
if I were all by myself and then it cuts
to Juliet in her bedroom alone when she
can't sleep she goes for a walk and
calls Walker telling her that it's time
to come home her plan is to turn the
badge in in the morning and resign after
talking to Regina she doesn't believe in
George anymore and Walker asked her if
she went up there for him or because it
was the right thing to do she responds
that he's not the person she thought he
was and Walker counters what kind of
person are you the man you love was
murdered and now you're saying it's a
waste of time to find out why and she
brings up the fact that she doesn't
leave her shop anymore before saying
that she's welcome to come here and join
her or she could just finish the job
right and that sends her back to
Regina's place where she calls her out
for being the informant Regina claims
that she didn't give up George to
judicial but then clarifies that they
actually come during the day and ask
easy questions the person that she did
give him up to is referred to as the man
who knows everything and he comes at
night she never makes it plain who this
is but you can tell that he scared the
crap out of her you can see signs that
she's still paranoid all this time later
and she explains the threats that were
leveled against her saying things like
every name she gave up would be less
days her mother would have to spend in
the mines whoever this person is has
power and is able to exert that to get
information that they want Jules
protests that George is dead because she
gave up his name and she counters that
he's dead because he wouldn't give up
the hard drive and she says she never
saw what was on it and I tend to believe
her she does say that he gave her
something and because of that she now
has nothing and when Jules asked what
she traded for the hard drive she does
give her a book that he got from his
mother her and her Aunt Gloria that had
been passed down for Generations
judicial never found this because it was
hidden in her doormat and I guess since
they were looking for the hard drive
they wouldn't have imagined it being
there she claims that this is from
before The Silo and warns that it's the
kind of thing that will get you killed
when she goes back to her apartment she
finds out it's a travel guide Amazing
Adventures in Georgia and the
inscription inside says Gloria and
George this clearly looks like something
that exists in our world inside she sees
forests and people white water rafting
animals and while she's looking at that
we see why Holston told her to double
the flowers in front of the mirror which
she didn't do as the shot pulls away we
see her on a monitor where two men
discussed waking him up because he has
to see this and now we'll have to wait
till next week to find out what's going
on there
I really like the way they use the watch
as a sort of universal symbol that spans
the whole season seeing its origin here
and how Jules tendency to want to fix
things added so much personal value for
her on top of the inherent value that
comes from it being a gift from the man
she loved of course the reveal of the
cameras is a big step forward in the
larger story but the reveal that George
doesn't appear to be the man she thought
he was has a massive impact on Jules
perception of reality there's a nice
parallel with how this object takes on
so many different meanings depending on
who sees it and how that relates to this
idea of Truth Jules had a very specific
question that she wanted to find the
answer to what happened to George and
because of who he was the pursuit of
that is leading her to places that she
would have never gone to on her own and
we watch in real time as the meaning of
the truth she's looking for evolves
what was he find what's going on with
all those cameras are they talking about
waking up SIMs or is there another
character behind that door we haven't
met yet when Regina was talking about
the man who knows everything I couldn't
tell if she was referring to Sims or not
he is a known agent of judicial the
volumes of books he has with the relics
in his office are interesting too
because they obviously contain
information that would get normal people
sent outside the Georgia travel guide is
a funny way to learn about what the
Earth used to look like and it's wild to
think how it contains so many things
they wouldn't have any idea wouldn't be
able to imagine and how it's only from a
relatively small part of the planet
compared to what's out there the last
few minutes of the episode were tense
and the payoff landed and now I can't
wait to see where the show goes next I
mentioned last week that there are a lot
of exciting elements that have been
added to keep book readers guessing and
that continues to be true this week none
of the this feels like a Divergence from
the core story but they have managed to
develop a situation where I can't say
for sure what will happen next and
that's exciting now that we're in the
back half of the season I might do a
video that discusses some of the
specific changes from the book to show
so stay tuned for that and I think
that's a great place to leave things
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon